hi guys sci-fi recapped here welcome
back to the black mirror series recap
before we start morning
spoilers ahead
today i'm going to explain a thriller
science fiction and one of the most
unsettling series from black mirror
season 3 called shut up and dance
this episode has an unpredictable plot
twist watch it till the end to find out
the movie starts with an unknown woman
parking her car in a basement then
leaving the key in the back of the wheel
arches before being texted and leaving
kenny is a socially awkward teenager who
works in a restaurant while being asked
to clean a spillage at the customer
table we can see that kenny has shown
some interest toward kids after work he
goes home and finds his sister linds is
borrowing his laptop and has
accidentally downloaded a virus to the
laptop he attempts to install an
anti-malware program and manages to
clean up the virus
however the hacker is still able to
access his laptop camera
one night when kenny's mom goes for a
date he feels bored and decides to lock
himself in his room he starts
masturbating to some pictures and his
action gets recorded by the hacker
suddenly kenny receives an email from
the hacker including the recording of
himself doing the things
he finally realizes that his laptop has
been hacked but it is already too late
the hacker emails kenny again and asks
him to reply with his phone number or
the video will be leaked he reluctantly
does so
the hacker text him to keep his phone
location on and charged telling him to
wait until he is activated
the next day kenny just arrives at work
when the hacker suddenly texts him and
demands him to go to a certain location
in 45 minutes
kenny has no choice but to obey the
hacker he manages to get there on time
meeting a motorcyclist with a package
who is also a victim of the hacker after
verifying the code written on the
package kenny is requested to deliver
the cake to a man in the hotel room
eventually being led in after informing
the occupant that mindy sent him kenny
meets hector a panicking kenny tries to
explain the situation to hector
discovering that hector is also being
blackmailed after he receives text
messages from the hacker left with no
choice the pair must obey and are told
to do a mission together the hacker
tells them to go to the hotel parking
basement and use the car the woman in
the beginning of the video dropped off
the pair are ordered to drive to a
specific location out of the city in a
very short time
on the way hector shares that he is
being blackmailed because of ordering a
prostitute named mindy on an unfamiliar
website and sharing a photo of himself
naked to the woman hector reveals that
he is already married and has a daughter
he is afraid that he will lose his
daughter unfortunately they have to stop
at a petrol station and meet hector's
wife friend hector lies that kenny is
his nephew who is going to birmingham by
train going in the same direction she
wants a lift and the pair has to
reluctantly agree
the hacker keeps sending them messages
saying that they are not in the right
route and only have 20 more minutes
remaining to reach the location
the moral of the story here is don't lie
long story short they barely make it to
the hacker's requested location the
hacker then tells them to look into the
cake where they find a gun sunglasses
and a hat they are ordered to rob a bank
but before that they must decide who
will commit the robbery and who will be
the driver deciding that kenny must go
hector waits in the car
kenny manages to rob the bank but ends
up wetting himself in sheer internalized
terror the pair escape and are told by
the hacker to go to the next place a
field
upon arrival hector is told to take the
car away and destroy it whilst kenny is
instructed to go into a nearby woodland
park alone to deliver the cash he just
stole
he makes his way into the park meeting a
man with a large box beside him the
large box actually contains a drone and
the man is told to launch the drone
before they proceed to the next order
the man then reveals that he is also a
victim of the hackers he tells kenny
that they must fight until death and the
last standing man will be the winner and
will take all the money as the drone
watches them from above
before starting to fight the man asks
kenny what he did and when kenny says
that all he did was look at pictures the
man also responds the same thing and
asks how young were they revealing
himself to be a pedophile kenny does not
answer which indicates that he is also
possessing pedophilic tendencies
kenny who still equipped himself with a
gun points it at the man then turns it
on himself but finds that it was empty
all along realizing that the man
approaches kenny and both of them engage
in a brutal fight
after completing all the mission hector
returns home and receives a troll
picture from the hacker he then finds
out that the hacker leaks the secret to
his wife as she says mindy the other
victims who complied with the hacker's
demand have also had their sensitive
information leaked and are sent troll
pictures
at the end of the movie kenny whose face
is covered with blood walks out from the
forest with the stolen money and
receives a call from his shocked mom
demanding to know what he has done it is
revealed that kenny had been
masturbating to child pictures and his
video has been sent to everyone he knows
as he receives a classic troll picture
from the hacker the police come and
arrest him
guys do you know that this is the only
second episode of black mirror series to
involve only technologies that existed
in real life at the time of its initial
release such as drones laptops and
classic smartphones
also the little girl in the restaurant
at the beginning of the movie is played
by annabelle jones's daughter who is
producer of black mirror series
she was cast due to difficulties with
finding parents who were willing to let
their child appear in an encounter that
takes on perverse undertones once the
final twist is revealed
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching